monday afternoon the miami herald
reported that
on october the 15th before brown signed
with the tampa bay buccaneers there was
an incident at a gated community
he resides out in hollywood florida
allegedly destroyed a security camera
allegedly threw a bicycle at a security
guard
shack police determined there was
probable cause to
charge antonio brown with criminal
mischief
misdemeanor level the homeowners
association manager decided not to in
part because she was concerned
that he may retaliate against employees
of the homeowners association so they
let it go
the wrinkle here is he's on probation
for a felony
charge arising from an altercation with
the driver of a moving truck back in
january so
even if you aren't charged for this
incident the authorities can swoop in
and say you'll run a foul of your
probation agreement you are going to
jail for that we're revoking your
probation
it's a privilege to be on probation you
have to dot eyes and cross t's and
there's a bunch of thou
shalt knots that you must adhere to this
would tend to be the kind of thing
that would get a guy in trouble it would
on his probation yeah now
will it get him in trouble with the
buccaneers no this was all breaking
yesterday while we were doing pftpm and
the buccaneer sent me a statement
during the show we're aware of the
reported incident involving antonio
brown prior to his signing
when antonio brown joined us we were
clear about what we expected and
required of him thus far he has met all
the expectations we have in place
that is a bunch of words that ultimately
means we aren't doing anything about
this yeah
it didn't it didn't happen since we
signed him even though chris
there's a chance they looked him in the
eye across the table and said
is there anything else we don't know
about and he said no there's nothing
else
and if they didn't do that they should
have done it and maybe they did it and
he said yeah there's this thing that
happened to you
where i got upset and i broke a camera
did he disclose that i don't know
but their statement makes it clear he's
getting a pass on this one
he's getting if he has any freebies he's
getting a freebie on this one yeah
no i mean you know they've already taken
the heat of
this situation now where they feel like
oh this you know this isn't a big enough
deal for them to get them off the
the hot seat as far as the antonio brown
conversation is going to go
let alone you know not get him off the
hot seat because we know brady wanted it
i mean that that's another thing too
here so yeah they're gonna
probably give him a little bit more
leash than most teams in football would
i don't know if he deserves that i'm
certainly not shocked about hearing news
of antonio brown causing an issue i mean
that
oh really i mean really surprised by
that one
you know but to me the interesting thing
is yes did this
did this catch tampa off guard or
were they aware i'm not sure which one's
worse really
i mean are you worse if you you're aware
of it and then sign them
i mean i i don't know in some ways i
look at that and go man
you were going to take a risk on a guy
and if he told you and you still took
the risk
you know then i don't care make you you
made your own bet in this conversation
but
um again i don't think this is going to
be the last story we'll hear about
antonio brown this year
it's a simple analysis either you didn't
pose the question the catch-all is there
anything else
or you did and he lied to you or you did
and he told you and you still
signed him none of those three outcomes
are good looks for the tampa bay
buccaneers no
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports